richardon like according to times Rich L
is worth 700 million quid right he'll
make 5% a year on that you know let's be
conservative say he makes 3% a year that
means he's making 21 million pound a
year passive income passive income
you're rich turn you spend a million
pound a year and that 20 million pound
you use that to buy assets right and you
know if it's a growing if you're in a
rapidly growing economy they can use
that to build new assets but we are not
in a rapidly growing economy so what
happens if your economy is not growing
and this guy is getting 20 million in
assets every year Well it has to come
from somewhere you know
so if you know I always think people
need to look at their family you know
and what percentage of your home did
your dad own when he was your age it's
going down right it's going down if you
look at like the youth home ownership is
collapsing right those houses are not
disappearing look at government debt
it's going through the roof look at
Mortgage Debt it's going through the
roof someone is on the other side of
that debt